طيب شاهد شاهد من اهله هذا ما طبقه سامي
رئيس شركه اوبن اي اي للذكاء الاصطناعي
التي تصنع
عندما حذر من مخاطر تلك التقنيه الجديد
اقترح تشكيل وكاله امريكيه او عالميه ترخص
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع
بسلطه سحب هذا الترخيص وضمان الامتثال
لمعايير السلامه
مع امكانيه استخدامه للغشوف بالفعل على
فكره الطلبي عم بيستخدموه
لكن هذه المخاوف توسعت لاحقا لتشمل
امكانيه تضليل الناس ونشر الاكاذيب فضلا
عن انتهاك حمايه حقوق الطبع والنشر والغاء
بعض الوظائف الوضع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات